what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some extremely major
MCU news about the one and only Dr Doom
there is a lot coming up in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe including Avengers
Secret Wars which in the comics Doctor
Doom in both stories of Secret Wars
plays a huge role in so is Marvel
Studios planning for that to be the same
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
introducing Doctor Doom to be a major
player in not just upcoming projects
like the Fantastic Four but in the New
Avengers films that we have coming up as
well don't worry Dr Doom is going to be
around far long after Secret Wars comes
and goes but it looks like his MCU debut
is not that far away seeing as how they
have reportedly offered a role to a
particular actor we'll break down
everything you need to know including
where Dr Doom could pop up in the MCU in
this video but first big reminder that
we start a new monthly giveaway today
I'll announce the winner for August and
tomorrow video so look out for that but
today starts a new giveaway for
September if you want to enter for a
chance to win an Xbox series X A PS5
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items just subscribe to the channel and
leave comments on our videos we pick a
random comment on a random video for a
winner and the winner gets to pick one
prize and we pick a winner at the end of
each month so according to a recent
report the actor Josh Hartnett has been
offered the role of Dr Doom this is
coming from Insider Jeff Snyder on the
hot mic podcast now right off the bat I
think this is an incredible Choice Josh
Hartnett is one of my favorite actors he
stars in one of my favorite movies Lucky
Number Slevin if you haven't seen that
check it out and of course he is known
for huge roles like Pearl Harbor and
Black Hawk Down and he was also recently
in Oppenheimer so needless to say a big
name actor huge actor which is kind of
what you probably want for Doctor Doom
because you're gonna want the actor
who's playing him to nail the roll and I
really think that Josh Hartnett could do
this Doctor Doom is possibly the
greatest Marvel villain to ever exist
and one of the reasons that he's so
great is that there are so many
different aspects to him sometimes he's
good sometimes he is extremely evil
sometimes even when he's bad he has to
team up with good people for the sake of
the entire universe because of course Dr
Doom can't have somebody else dominate
the universe or the Multiverse for that
matter he's an incredibly powerful
sorcerer he even teams up with Doctor
Strange to go into the hell Dimension to
take on Mephisto of course he is a
classic Fantastic Four villain but not
just to the Fantastic Four pretty much
to everybody in the secret War story in
the comics he becomes God Emperor Doom
where Doctor Strange works for him and
he has a whole Thor core where a bunch
of different variants of Thor work for
him as well plus not to mention he is a
genius and he's incredibly sophisticated
and Suave and I think Josh Hartnett
could really pull off this character but
right away go ahead and let us know your
thoughts about this down below do you
think Josh Hartnett would make a good
Doctor Doom now as far as where Dr Doom
could pop up first in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I know a lot of
people are thinking the Fantastic Four
reboot movie obviously he is a huge
Fantastic Four villain his Origins are
rooted right next to Reed Richards they
went to the same College they were even
roommates so on the surface it would
seem like a pretty obvious choice to
include or introduce Dr Doom in the
Fantastic Four film however this might
not be the case According to some
Insider reports that we've heard in the
past there isn't really much plans for
Dr Doom and the Fantastic Four reboot
movie from what we've heard Galactus is
going to be the main villain of the film
now don't get me wrong anything could
change right now especially since the
industry is dealing with writer strikes
and actor strikes right now Marvel
Studios could be coming up with ideas
right now for the Fantastic Four film
and when the writers come back they
could say hey we've actually decided to
change a few things and we're gonna put
Dr Doom in this movie now so we're not
really sure about that but previous
reports have stated that Dr Doom isn't
going to be in the Fantastic Four movie
and if he is he's either going to be
just kind of hinted at or or slightly
introduced and they're going to try to
make it pretty casual and not seem like
a pretty big deal but of course to us
major Marvel fans will know and of
course will freak out but again anything
could change during this time of the
strikes now if this is true and he's not
going to be introduced in the Fantastic
Four then what movie will he be
introduced in well our next thought is
Avengers Secret Wars or somewhere in
between Avengers Kang Dynasty and
Avengers Secret Wars I don't think it
makes too much sense for him to jump
into Kang Dynasty right away that's
pretty much going to be about the new
Avengers team taking on King the
Conqueror in which we believe Kang is
going to win we believe it's pretty much
going to be like Avengers Infinity War
where Thanos wins at the end and then in
game is where the heroes come in and
kind of avenge what happened in Infinity
War so it's going to be pretty much the
same for Kang Dynasty We Believe Kang is
going to win and the Multiverse is
either going to be completely destroyed
or ruled entirely by Kang the Conqueror
and this is where they're going to need
to start to try and fix the Multiverse
and defeat King and if you're trying to
fix the Multiverse and you're getting
people like the smartest man alive
involved Reed Richards then it would
make sense to probably get Victor Von
Doom involved he is still a genius and
perhaps his origin and the MCU won't
exactly be evil perhaps Secret Wars
makes him evil now I am hoping the
Rivalry with Reed Richards is there
because that is what gives him a major
push the realization that somebody out
there was more advanced was stronger and
was actually capable of controlling not
only one universe but multiple universes
perhaps King the Conqueror is what
pushes him to become Doctor Doom now I
do have a theory about what could
possibly happen in Avengers Secret Wars
yes he could appear in some film in
between Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars and
they could seek his help to try and
figure out a way to fix the Multiverse
by helping read Richard's but if he
appears in secret Wars then perhaps we
could see a slight variation of a comic
story from Secret Wars play out in the
MCU in one of the secret Wars stories
it's revealed that the beyonder took all
of the Heroes and all the villains and
separated them saved their lives from a
destroyed Multiverse but pinned them
against each other and basically said
whoever wins I will grant you your
biggest desire I'll give you whatever
you want but ultimately what ends up
happening is Dr Doom takes the power of
the beyonder and becomes God Emperor
doom and then he rules over battle world
it is possible that something like this
could happen in the MCU however instead
of the beyonder it will be Kang but
perhaps Dr Doom could take Kang's
technology because this is right in Dr
Doom's will house he would see somebody
that is more technologically advanced
than himself and he would want all of
that technology that that person had so
if Dr Doom sees Kang he's definitely
going to scheme and try to figure out
how to get Kang's technology away from
him and use that for himself and if he
does get his hands on it perhaps that
could be how Dr Doom becomes a major
villain in the MCU now I think A
variation of this could happen however I
do believe the focus will stay on Prime
Kang or King the Conqueror but perhaps a
version of Victor Von Doom could pop up
from a different universe who has taken
over Kang and has his technology he
could show up and try to help the
Avengers fight the prime Kang but no
matter what even in this scenario like I
mentioned Victor Von Doom is always
scheming and sometimes yes he does have
to fight with the heroes in order to
defeat a greater villain but Victor Von
Doom is always trying to end up on top
himself he hates to lose and not to
mention in the comics there is a point
in time where Kang kind of gets time
displaced and he runs into Doctor Doom
and he believes that Doctor Doom might
be an ancestor of his in fact that's how
we get the Scarlet Centurion Kang models
his armor of the Scarlet Centurion after
the armor of Doctor Doom so there
actually are connections between King
the Conqueror and Victor Von Doom and
there is a president in Marvel Comics
for Dr Doom to take control over who's
left out of all the heroes and villains
when the Multiverse gets destroyed this
is a storyline that could play out that
could keep the focus on King The Conch
curb they could have a little Side Story
for Doctor Doom But ultimately keep the
focus on Kane but sets up Doctor Doom to
be the next big bad of phase seven phase
8 phase nine whatever they're gonna call
the next Saga because we obviously know
that Dr Doom is not a one and done
villain he's a major villain like I
mentioned one of the absolute best
villains in Marvel history so when they
do introduce him don't expect him to be
one and done but expect him to be around
for a pretty long time at least we hope
it would be an absolute shame if Dr Doom
only appeared in the Multiverse Saga for
one or two movies but considering how
the Fantastic Four are going to be a
pretty big part of the MCU moving
forward after Secret Wars I'm assuming
Doctor Doom is going to be a pretty big
part of it too and this really would set
him up big time to be a big villain in
the next phase if Galactus is the True
Villain of the mcu's Fantastic Four
debut film then you know the next movie
will probably have Dr Doom as the main
villain or perhaps they could even just
skip that and go right to having him be
the next Avengers villain because I do
believe Josh Harnett is going to be cast
as the main villain of this universe our
main Universe not a variant From Another
Universe but our universe otherwise this
casting wouldn't really be that big of a
deal but it looks like Marvel Studios
could have a major player coming to the
MCU as Dr Doom Josh artnet which again
I'm really excited about and I think is
a really great choice but let us know
your thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news you
can find us on Instagram and Twitter as
well and as always thank you all so much
for watching woof woof
please
foreign